throw them out while show after our
discussion yesterday about the
masculinity crisis and Andrew Tate I
heard from many young men who told me
that they have no choice but to give up
on marriage and family and go their own
way but is this kind of surrender really
the answer no definitely not I'll
explain why also the daily wire report
reveals the program by the
Anti-Defamation League that's being used
to politically indoctrinate children in
Florida schools prescriptions for
puberty blockers Skyrocket over the
Skyrocket over the last two years a
prominent Native American activist in
Wisconsin turns out to be Native
American in the same sense that Caitlyn
Jenner is a woman and in our daily
cancellation we'll deal with one of the
newest trends on Tick Tock stay-at-home
girlfriends all of that and more today
on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
if you're someone who has always wanted
to read and understand the Bible but
you're not sure where to start then
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension Bible New Year podcast is
currently the most popular religion
podcast in the U.S millions of people
have listened to it and twice it's hit
the number one spot on Apple podcast in
the Bible in a year father Mike Schmitz
reads the entire Bible in 365 daily
episodes providing helpful commentary
Reflections and prayers along the way
what better way to start the new year
than this you can find the Bible into
your podcast with father Mike Schmitz
for free and your favorite podcast app
or on YouTube plus you can follow along
with a special reading plan to help you
better understand the story
unlike any other Bible podcast Bible in
a year follows a special reading plan
that organizes the books of the Bible in
a way that helps listeners understand
the story you can get this reading plan
at ascensionpress.com Welsh if you want
to start reading and more importantly
understanding the Bible this year go to
ascensionpress.com Walsh to download the
reading plan for free that's
accenturepress.com Walsh to download the
reading plan for free
we opened the show yesterday with a
discussion about the crisis of
masculinity and the rise of Andrew Tate
and to very Briefly summarize the key
points made in that conversation bullies
are growing up in a culture that is
openly hostile to masculinity and many
are forced to navigate the Minefield
without the benefits of strong male role
models to show them the path and this
crisis is self-perpetuating it grows
exponentially because the young men with
absentee fathers eventually become
absentee fathers themselves repeating
the cycle indefinitely unto infinity and
into this field of confusion and man
hatred steps guys like Andrew Tate and
others quickly earning an enormous
following of young men who
understandably flock to somebody who has
a message that Embraces masculinity
rather than treating it like a disease
Andrew Tate very often good at
identifying the problems in our culture
as they pertain to the situation at men
phase and deserves credit for speaking
up in defense of masculinity rather than
denigrating it and calling for its
eradication essentially but in my view
he misses the mark when it comes to the
remedy he seems to basically understand
the disease but he doesn't have the
right prescription for it or at least
the full prescription
yes men should reject the programming
that our culture wants to subject them
to uh programming which seeks to neuter
and feminize them yes they should work
hard they should take care of their
minds and their bodies yes they should
strive for Success including financial
success
but a life of Hedonism and materialism
and luxurious wealth remaining unmarried
while sleeping with a dozens of
different women and so on
is not the ideal to strive towards
rather what men are called to and
created for and the only sort of life
that will be truly happy that they'll
find true happiness and joy in is a life
of service as protector and provider
men the vast majority of men anyway are
called to be husbands and fathers to be
leaders of their families now they may
be called to lead in other ways too but
first they must care for their families
if there's any saving
our civilization at this point
which I think there is
but if there is this is how we'll be
done and this is who will do it
it's not going to be saved by
influencers who are sitting in front of
cameras whether the guy in front of the
camera is Andrew Tate or me or anyone
else it'll be saved through the
formation and preservation of strong
intact loving and well-led Families
that is the only way it is the only way
forward
if every man in the country starts going
to the gym and starts making lots of
money and starts having sex with lots of
attractive women and yet they don't get
married and stay married and have
children and raise and love those
children
then we will still be headed to ruin
it'll be a slightly different kind of
Ruin but ruin all the same
those men themselves will ultimately
find the happiness that uh that they are
able to derive in that lifestyle they'll
find that it's shallow and it's fleeting
and in the end
they'll die alone loved by no one loving
no one
remembered by no one leaving no Legacy
behind
the feminized and neutered and
effeminate man that are left-wing
culture seeks to create and then this
other sort of man both unmarried both
childless
will look very similar in the end
having taken two very different paths
just to arrive together at essentially
the same place
it's the family man the devoted father
and husband whose different path
actually leads to a different and much
better conclusion
now I've of course been preaching this
message for as long as I've had an
audience to preach to and I have found
that
there are like two or three basic
responses or rebuttals I guess that I
always hear from young men who who may
for the most part line up with me
ideologically but who doubt the wisdom
of the get married and have kids
prescription
and I was greeted with these same
responses after the show yesterday and
many messages and comments what I'd like
to do today is answer
the objections or at least what seems to
be the one principal objection
the claim that I so often hear is that
well marriage and family life is a trap
it's a scam
especially for men the whole thing is
rigged against us
there is nothing for a man to do but
give up on the entire Enterprise and and
go his own way
in fact there's a whole movement online
men go their own way and that's
basically the idea
give up on this stuff and and do
something else
this argument was summarized in a
comment from a listener named Joshua
which I'll read because I think it just
is representative of this sort of
mentality he says still sounds like mad
in most tradcons definition of what
masculinity means is exclusively through
the lens of women and children's wants
and needs unfortunately that ideal will
no longer work in the modern world with
birth control hookup culture social
media and court systems that favor women
in the denigration of traditional
masculinity I don't agree with all of
Tate's views but it sure beats Matt's
prescriptions for young men
again I've read a great many comments
making the same kind of point a private
message from another listener has a
similar theme says Matt I agree with
many of your opinions but your message
to men is off base young men follow
Andrew Tate because his lifestyle is the
ideal whether you admit it or not wealth
Fame status beautiful women were
biologically programmed to want those
things marriage is a losing game The
Only Solution in modern society is to
reject the life of service as you call
it
so what is the problem with uh this view
well to begin with
it's nothing less than a full
unconditional surrender to the culture
it's true that the culture has
increasingly made it difficult for both
men and women to form and maintain
strong intact lasting families and
that's because the elites who run our
society don't want you to live that kind
of life
they prefer that you focus on your
individual wants
unfulfilling your own needs and
satisfying your own desires that's what
they prefer for you that's the life they
want for you A self-focused life is
precisely the sort of Life they wish for
you
makes you easier to manipulate less of a
threat to their agenda
not really a threat at all I mean if
you're just out there focused on
yourself
um you know being a consumer buying lots
of things for yourself consuming things
for yourself
um you know and all the rest of it
you're not a threat to to their agenda
at all I mean you're going along with it
um all of the things mentioned by Joshua
and his comment
all of those things represent a
conspiracy against the families right
about that
the way the family court systems are set
up birth control all the rest of it
it's an attack on the Family
so what is the answer to give up
to give the conspirators exactly what
they want to reward them for their
efforts by turning your back on the very
thing they've been assaulting for
decades
the family is the Fortress that they
have been attacking
and you can defend it with your life or
you can wave the white flag
but if you choose to surrender then at
least be honest about what you're doing
be honest this is not a rejection of the
left's agenda of a cultural Elites
agenda you are you are submitting to it
it is a submission
it is certainly not the strong or
masculine response to run away and
abandon your post
to stop fighting because the fight is
too difficult
I mean that approaches many things but
it certainly isn't manly
and where do you go instead I mean what
is the next move
to give up on the families to give up on
human civilization
seeing as how there cannot be a human
civilization without the family so
uh what's Plan B after you've given up
on civilization where what's next
you're also giving up on yourself on
your own legacy your own bloodline your
you are descended from a long line of
men stretching back thousands of years
who formed families and raised children
offer often under circumstances far more
dire than what we face
and you're giving up on them too
you you are surrendering your future and
your past you're giving up on everything
and what is your consolation prize
finding financial success
I mean the unfortunate irony is that
many of the people that many of The Men
Who uh give up on these things in in
favor of well just focus on myself and
try to be financially successful many of
them are never even going to be
Financial financially successful so they
end up with just nothing they end up
broke and alone with nothing
but even if you find it
the financial success
so what I mean who cares about money if
you have nothing meaningful to spend it
on
I have money I I don't have Andrew
Tate's money but I have money
then nearly all the joy and happiness I
derive from having money is that it
allows me to provide for my family
that's pretty much it that's the entire
thing that's why I like having the money
is that I find great pleasure in being
able to care for a wife and six kids
proud of that fact
if I didn't have them the money would
mean very little to me I mean I could
buy nice things and drive a fancy car
and live in my nice house alone
but for what
now does that mean that if you start a
family that you're guaranteed to live a
joyful and fulfilled life well of course
not it's a risk
and yes the risks are in some ways much
greater in modern times we have all been
poisoned by this demonic culture to one
extent or another we are all poisoned
if you marry someone you are marrying
someone who has been poisoned who has
ingested the poison
who has uh you know had taken a drink
from The Well of modern culture
everybody has as have you and yes if
things go sideways
if you're a man you marry a woman and
your wife turns out to be a disloyal
vulture
or if you turn out to be a disloyal
vulture or you both do
um the deck will be stacked against you
in court no no there's no question about
that
divorce May ruin your life
and you know if you give your heart to
someone if you bind yourself to them not
only through the marriage vow but then
also through children you conceive
together
then you will have they will have all
they need
to rip your guts out and burn your life
to the ground that is absolutely true
that's the risk okay but it's a risk
worth taking
every great joy can become a great
tragedy if you aren't careful
or if you have very bad luck
that's true
so is the answer then to forgo all joy
to say forget about Joy because it might
not work out
to embrace a life of loneliness and
misery because you're worried that if
you aim higher you'll end up
lonely and miserable
you're worried that in the end you'll
end up in this state so instead you say
well I might as well just live in this
state to begin with
doesn't make any sense
so you take the risk
and you mitigate the risk at the same
time by being smart about who you marry
and by grounding your marriage and and
your family in faith and mutual devotion
and by working hard every day to hold up
your own end of the bargain
because yeah there are some men out
there who do everything right and
they're and and and you know they're
great men and they're devoted to their
families and they're intensely loyal and
all of that and their families fall
apart anyway because they accidentally
married a soulless disloyal scumbag I
mean that does happen and sometimes it
happens in the reverse
but that's not
that's not the majority of cases
most of the time it takes two to tango
two to get married two to ruin the
marriage
which means that marriage is not a mere
role of the dice
there's quite a lot you can do to secure
your good fortune
that's why I never cared about the
statistics you know when I get was
getting married and I heard about this
statistically this is I'm not a
statistic
I'm not just some number on a
spreadsheet
and neither is my wife we're human
beings
I I'm not subject to statistics
not merely subject to them
because the one thing statistics don't
take into account are choices
it's about the choices you make
whether your marriage works or not it's
about choices that are made in the
marriage
if one or both of you make bad choices
your your chances are going to be very
poor if you make good choices they won't
be that's what it is
and yet the risk is always there so will
you live in fear of it
or will you have the courage
and go forward anyway
one other thing I want to say you know I
I and this is important to say that
it's just not true okay it's just not
true that a life of obscene luxury and
materialism and selfishness and
self-service and of you know sleeping
with many different women and and all of
that it's not true that that is the
ideal
which we so often hear these days that's
the ideal
you know non-monogamy having many sexual
partners that's the ideal they say
that's not true
much less is it is it what we are
biologically programmed to desire
no it's what we're culturally programmed
to desire that is the cultural
programming
but I know that it's not biological
because I'm a biological organism and I
don't desire that
I don't want any life but the one I have
I don't want any woman but the one I
married
I mean you could listen to that and say
oh that's not true he's just saying
that's a cope on your part
that's resentment Envy talking
if I could do my life over from the
start I would find my wife again and
marry her again if I lived 100 lives I'd
marry her in all of them
that's what it means to love somebody
and love is the ideal
because it's Not Mere biological
programming it is transcendent
and trust me it's well worth the risk
now let's get to our headlines
you know how I feel about New Year's
resolutions you set out with lofty goals
stick to them for two weeks then fall
right back into your old habits well
lucky for you I have a goal that you can
accomplish today complete your will with
epic will for just 119 bucks and in as
little as five minutes epic will can
help you create your last will and
testament your living will even
Healthcare power of attorney their
step-by-step online form makes it
incredibly easy all you got to do is
fill in the blanks uh 50 of Americans
don't have a will well you can choose
today to be in the smarter half
but you got to go to epicwell.com use
promo code Walsh to save 10 percent on
Epic Will's package that's the
epicwill.com promo code Walsh
all right we begin with this headline
from the daily wire after DeSantis says
Florida is where woke goes to die
Broward schools Inc contract with
radical left group
this is the article from Luke rosiak
says a month after Republican governor
Ron DeSantis won a resounding
re-election Victory and declared the
state is where woke Goes To Die the
state's second largest school system
signed a contract with an Infamous
Peddler of woke partisanship for
children on December 13th the Broward
County school board approved a contract
with the Anti-Defamation League
otherwise known as ADL the contract
managed by the school district's
Department of diversity and school
climates
expands an existing program already
present in 70 of its schools called no
place for hate which proclaims move on
from kindness schools need to Foster
social justice wait a second
move on from kindness
schools need to Foster social justice
so we don't want to be kind anymore with
kindness that's old news we're moving on
from kindness and instead we have
social justice
because of course I guess what they're
admitting here is that social justice
has nothing to do with kindness
certainly has nothing to do with love or
being you know anti-hate or anything
um the move calls for training select
student leaders of no place for hate
under adl's a world of difference
program
the contract says that that ADL will
cover the cost of training a document
for a world of difference calls for
preschoolers to learn to take a stand
no place for Hate's coordinator handbook
and resource guide for 2020 to 2021
calls to get them involved in action
advocacy and or activism
in order to affect systemic change
students need to analyze and challenge
the opportunity achievement Gap school
funding inequities and the school to
prison pipeline
okay so these are public schools that
are
focused now on getting kids including
preschoolers involved in activism
uh let's see it goes on
people of color and or those who are
members of marginalized groups may want
to share real and sometimes harsh
testimonies about their experiences they
may want to caucus with others in their
same identity group in order to feel
safe or they may feel that being able to
challenge others by bias is what is
necessary to build empathy different
perspectives may be attributed to uh to
whether one is part of a marginalized or
majority group in school or Society
if you know students correct pronouns
and names use them in class and do not
rely on official or roster information
no place for Hate's website lists as a
resource
um
ADL lesson plans
free and pre-assembled attracting
teachers who want to save the work of
creating their own plans which push
naked partisanship on children one
titled Georgia's restrictive voting law
states that quote in March 2021 the
Georgia state legislature passed a major
law that restricts and suppresses voting
across the state
it encourages students to plan actions
they can take to influence powerful
entities to take a stand about social
justice issues
and then many many similar things like
this so this is still going on in the
school system second largest school
system in in uh in Florida and this is
still happening there even after
um
even after we're told that you know woke
goes to die in Florida so this is
something that
Ron Santos needs to pay attention to
needs to work towards doing something
about this
um even just the the fact that there's a
what was it what was their exact
phrasing and every school has different
phrases different department of
diversity and school plan climate
well that shouldn't exist
in any school there should be any
Department of diversity if they've got
anything like that you know from the
start that this is a mechanism to
ideologically indoctrinate students
and so they should begin by getting rid
of all of those every Department of
diversity in any school needs to be gone
and it also goes to show that the
parental rights bill which was uh
inappropriately named misnamed the don't
say gay bill that has to be just the
beginning you know that can't be the
whole story
um
even that bill you know I I supported
that bill was a good bill
it was a good law
better than the alternative the
alternative was nothing
but that bill was specifically focused
on protecting kids from sexual
indoctrination from pre-k up to third
grade
which is which is great to protect them
from that but then now we've got all the
students who are in fourth grade and
higher gonna protect them too
and there are other forms of
indoctrination also
so pushing preschoolers to get involved
in left-wing activism
having these blatantly partisan you know
uh lessons about voting laws and and how
voter ID counts as voter suppression
well that's not sexual indoctrination
but that is I did that is a political
and ideological indoctrination
so that needs to go out the window also
and this is where
you know as I always say when it comes
to the most politicians I don't support
at all I don't trust most of them
and on the rare occasion that I find a
politician who I will say I support the
support is always tentative and I'm
willing to I'm willing to withdraw it at
any moment
it's like they have to continue to earn
that's that's I think it's the attitude
we should all have towards politicians
and that means it's not like you earn it
and then you skate on that for the next
decade you got to continue to earn
which means even if someone supports
Ron's especially someone who supports
Ron DeSantis I'm looking at this and
saying well okay let's see what he does
next
because it can that's a that's a great
Bill glad it was passed
now what's next
you got all these other kids we need to
protect all these other forms of
indoctrination
um let's do that next
and I think he will I hope he will
uh but really
the other thing that we I think we could
take from this is that there shouldn't
be
you know anytime you hear about
discussions of hate in the schools it's
not what this is supposed to be
taking a stand against hate no place for
hate
it's actually not the school's job to
tell kids what they should or shouldn't
hate
there there actually should not be any
conversations in the school system
um about hatred we don't need the
government employees who are running the
school system to facilitate these
conversations with kids about hatred
that's not your job none of this is your
job
pushing them to activism to getting into
getting involved in social movements
none of that is your job
your job is to teach the academic
subjects and that's it
all the rest of this is moral formation
and that's not your job that's not why
anyone is actually sending their kids to
the public school system
and the reason why I'm not going to
trust the school system with moral
formation
is that I I don't I don't agree with or
trust their moral viewpoints what they
consider moral formation is is really
moral deformation
and when it comes to hate I certainly am
not going to trust the schools to tell
my kids what is appropriate hate and
what is and what they should and
shouldn't be hating
because guess what not all hate is bad
everyone actually agrees with that
as much as they tell us there's no place
for hate that's not true
there's always a place for hate even
they would say that
I'm sure they would say tell us that we
should hate racism
I'm sure they would tell us that we
should hate utterly fundamentally reject
you know intolerance
well no they wouldn't tell us to
fundamentally reject either of those
things because they're in favor of some
forms of racism but but that's what they
would say
if I if you were to ask them even the
ones who are who put together this no
place for hate program if you were to
ask them well you know what about is
racism a detestable thing they would say
absolutely okay so we should detest
racism we should hate it okay well so
there is a place for hatred actually
there are things that are worthy of
hatred it's just a matter of what are
those things
that's about that's a value system
judgment
and um
I don't trust the school system's value
system
all right
speaking of things we should hate here's
a report from the gay groomer site pink
news about child drag queens and there's
a lot going on in this brief clip that
will play that they tell us is just is
not real it's all misinformation and yet
here it is in their video it's not my I
didn't but I didn't put this video
together this is their video and uh
let's watch
me Australia's youngest drag queen 13
year old candy feather bottom also known
as Logan out of drag hi everybody I'm
candy feather bottom and 15 year old
Queen Cherry West from Edinburgh
Scotland also known as Sam Carling out
of drag hello divas and Cherry West the
red Betty Ben rotten I am a 15 year old
drag queen though from different parts
of the world these Queens have more than
just their young age in common but their
passion for all things drag Candy's love
and passion for singing and Performing
came from watching a family-friendly
performance at the local Bowls Club by
group taboo and led to her drag debut at
the North Ipswich Bowls Club in Brisbane
at just 10 years old getting up on a
stage and you know bringing that smiles
to those people's faces is why I do it
and Cherry's inspiration came from
watching her drag icon Bianca Del Rio a
queen that inspired me quite a lot was
Bianca Del Rio from season six of
driveways and I recently seen her in
Edinburgh performing and she's
absolutely incredible I'm obsessed with
her the Trailblazers are challenging
perceptions on young Queens through not
only their cell performances but through
speaking up for all of the kids finding
out who they are
oh there you go perfect example of what
we just talked about there are some
things worthy of hatred not hating the
kids it's not their fault they're
victims this is this is sexual abuse
they are sexual abuse victims we don't
hate them
we hate what's being done to them
that's what we hate
and you hear it right there in the video
I mean this is this is grooming
and that's that's why we're they don't
want us to it's like they've banned the
word and it's this horrible slur because
it's true that's why we're not allowed
to say it anything you're not allowed to
say these days because it's true
you even hear the kids say it they they
say that well I said you know I saw uh
drag when I was 10 years old and that's
what made me decide I wanted to get into
drag
that's grooming that's indoctrination
that's exactly why they want to expose
the kids to this kind of stuff so that
the kids will emulate it
because children are impressionable
and if you put something in front of
their faces and say this is cool this is
what you should be doing they're very
likely to listen to that
so this is uh this is exactly the point
it is full-on grooming and uh and sexual
abuse
not all that different from you know
what is it the Afghanistan the uh
Taliban a bakabazzi I think they call it
very similar thing they take adolescent
boys dress them up like girls have them
dance around for the for the uh
as a spectacle for grown pervert men who
sit there and watch it
similar idea
a little bit of a different you know
different words different uh it's it's
cloaked in a kind of a different way
but very similar idea
well here's a very brief Tick Tock from
uh this is a therapist here in Nashville
and a therapist is named Bailey Joe
Carter
and it's like six seconds long and
there's no audio in it but here she is
bragging about using suicide threats to
manipulate parents go ahead and watch
this real quick all eyes on me
horrified looks from everyone in the
room a client's mom and said do you want
a transgender kid or a dead kid
so this is her
saying this is what she says to parents
you want a trans kid or a dead kid
um and this is of course what therapists
and counselors have been saying to
parents for many years now
to manipulate them it's emotional
blackmail to get them to go along with
their gender transition
and it's especially when I mean this is
this is
horrifically evil they know exactly what
they're doing
also keep it keep in mind something here
that
you know very often when the therapists
say this to the parents
the parents go to the therapist they
bring the kid in as they say the child's
struggling with gender dysphoria feels
not at home in his own body whatever it
is
um
very often and there are plenty of
parents that will tell you this if you
talk to them the therapist will bring up
suicide as a possibility even if the
child never mentioned anything about
Suicidal Thoughts
it's the therapist and the counselors
who will introduce this idea to the
parent and the child
but even if the child had brought it up
now even even if the child who was
struggling with this gender confusion
had already on his own or on her own
brought up these Suicidal Thoughts
that still would not make this okay at
all for the therapist to take this
approach
because why are the children suicidal
why are they you know if you're suicidal
you're in a state of despair every
single suicidal person that's ultimately
what
what brings about the suicide is a state
of despair
and what are they despairing over
what's the source of that despair
it's because they they you know are
unable to accept themselves for who they
actually are
you know they feel like there's
something
wrong with their body something wrong
with them in in a way that can never be
fixed they feel not at home in their own
bodies
and it's quite easy to see how that
would bring about feelings of despair
so what's the what's the solution then
the solution is to help them to accept
themselves for who they are
and what one of the things that makes
this so infuriating is just how
easy it would be in so many of these
cases
every once in a while you have a kid
where the gender confusion gender
dysphoria is is much more deeply seated
and it would take them and it takes a
lot longer to um
help them navigate their way through it
to treat it
this could still be done though
I mean there's it does it doesn't matter
how deep it is there's never a time when
you should just give in to it and say
okay well if you feel like you're this
other gender then you must be that's
never the solution it's never the right
thing
you know with so many of these kids it's
it's not that deeply seated
all they need is just a little bit of
clarity if they had a little bit of
clarity
that's all they would need and they'd
get over it
for many of these kids it's it's a very
surface level level thing
and you shed a little bit of light give
them a little bit of guidance
for many of these kids you know in the
beginning look all they need to hear is
from an adult they trust if you've got a
boy who thinks he's a girl or is saying
that
all he needs to hear from some adult he
trusts is no you're a boy it's a good
thing to be a boy it's wonderful to be
who you are uh that you you should
embrace that and accept that
that's all he needs to hear
but he doesn't and so what starts as
this kind of surface level confusion
eventually becomes much more deeply
seated
uh and this also sheds some light on
this report from the post-millennial
says the number of American children
being treated for gender dysphoria has
risen sharply in recent years with
prescriptions for puberty blockers
doubling between 2017 and 2021 according
to the Daily Mail the data comes from
health insurance reports meaning the
actual numbers are likely to be much
higher due to the number of patients
paying out of pocket for the
experimental and harmful treatments
the meteoric rise in American doctors
attempting to perform sex changes on
minors
has occurred while other nations are
starting to move away from affirmation
and puberty suppression and back to a
more cautious psychotherapeutic approach
to this for those uh for this vulnerable
cohort of young people Sweden Finland
England France New Zealand have all
recently abandoned the affirmative model
of care due to concerns that the risks
far outweigh the benefits
The Daily Mail took data collected by
Komodo Health an analytics company that
monitors health insurance claims and
created graphs showing this explosion in
young people being diagnosed and treated
for gender dysphoria
the data shows the prescriptions for
period lockers for those aged 6 to 17
left from 633 in 2017 to 1 390 in 2021
these drugs were once thought to be a
fully reversible pause to give a child
more time to figure out their identity
but recent Studies have shown that
almost almost every child put on puberty
blockers goes on to take cross-sex
hormones meaning the drugs make further
medical transition almost a foregone
conclusion
according to Daily Mail report the
number of insurance claims for young
people taking cross-sex hormones soared
from a little under 2000 in 2017 to
4231 in 2021 so you're seeing a doubling
and this again you know anytime you see
numbers like this it's always going to
be an under count
for the reasons that
they say in the post-millennial report
but also because
you know the the people that we're
relying on for this information have
every incentive to under to give you an
under count
the people in the health industry the
pharmaceutical industry
it doesn't do them any good to actually
give us the real numbers
because the more we see that and we see
this explosion
um the more it makes people kind of
recoil and say well what the heck's
going on here
you see a doubling a tripling whatever
quadrupling
that makes even people who have been
totally oblivious to this point they sit
up they take notice and they say what
wait why is that happening
that's exactly the question
that the medical industry doesn't want
you to ask
so even with this under count
even coming from sources that are biased
in the other direction
you can still see the the social
contagion very clearly in action
and from Madison 365
um actually I won't tell you the
headline yet I want to read from the
article a little bit and you can tell me
if if you see where this is going
okay if you're very insightful and
you've been paying attention you might
you might pick up on this you might you
might guess the twist ending before we
even get to it
early in 2020 an indigenous artists
urged the owners of a new music venue in
town to change its name
it was called the Winnebago after the
street on which it stands many
indigenous people and allies let the
owners know that that wasn't the best
name for a white-owned music venue one
of them was
oh great okay here's the name this
person was going by
it's gonna take me a second
Midway okay that's the name that she was
going by also known as K Leclair that's
actually her name a founding member and
co-owner of the queer indigenous artist
Collective and uh budding leader of
Madison's indigenous Arts community
took several months but the venue
eventually relented and rebranded as the
Burr Oak
LeClaire wrote an editorial for our
lives Wisconsin at the time I'm glad the
owners have decided to no longer profit
from the identities of indigenous people
I'm glad the name is going but I'm not
happy that the institutions that allowed
it to be stolen in the first place
remain for over 500 years indigenous
peoples have not controlled our
narratives and representations our
exclusion has been built into inclusion
for others
one problem with that narrative this is
the part you've already guessed Leclair
wasn't indigenous and was in fact
profiting from the identities of
indigenous peoples herself
so since at least 2017 Kayla Claire has
claimed Menace Oneida uh Cuban and
Jewish Heritage along with a couple
other indigenous cultures that I'm not
even trying to pronounce additionally
they identify as two Spirits a term many
indigenous people use to describe a
non-binary gender identity actually
almost no indigenous people use that
term but whatever in addition to
becoming a member of a and co-owner of
this Arts Collective LeClaire earned
several artists stipends a paid
residency at the University of Wisconsin
a place on the missing and murdered
indigenous women task force and many
speaking Gates and art exhibitions not
to mention a platform and Trust of the
community
um and this all in spite of the fact
that this person apparently and then
it's a very long story that goes on from
there but apparently this person
invented the entire uh indigenous
Persona and this is you know a white
person has no real indigenous blood so
same story we've seen it up it's
actually interesting because in this
article from Madison 365 which is the
local Wisconsin uh news Outlet
they still refer to K Leclair as they so
they respect the they pronoun
because you know she identifies as
two-spirit which supposedly is the
indigenous or Native American version of
trans or non-binary which as I've told
you before it's not that's a that's a
two-spirit is a is a term invented by
gay activists in 1990 okay it's not it's
not something that goes back
um into the ancient past all right it's
not like it's not like the the Mayans
were identifying themselves as
two-spirit but
so they're still there's the funny thing
about it they're still respecting that
so it's clear that she lied about her
whole identity she's come up with
multiple false identities she's Cuban
one minute she's Jewish the next she's
indigenous this she belongs to this
tribe that tribe and uh all that is fake
but they're still respecting the gender
identity and refer because that couldn't
possibly be fake right and so they're
still going to refer to her as that
but you know it's it's the same story
we've seen so many times that's why you
could guess the ending before we even
got there uh people white white people
and it's it's you know it is interesting
that it's so often white women in
particular it's not that men never do
this but it's it is very often white
women
who um
invent this minority identification for
themselves
which is very fascinating
because if we indeed of course lived in
a society with systemic racism and
systemic uh oppression of these various
groups
then why would you have so many people
who are in the group in power
clamoring to get to to be identified
with the persecuted group
there is no precedent for that in
history
there's plenty of precedent for actually
persecuted groups in a society
but what you find is that if you go back
to you know any historical precedent of
a of a persecuted group you don't have
people in the in the powerful group
trying to falsely identify themselves as
members of the persecuted group
it usually goes the other way where
people in the persecuted group are
trying to claim identity outside of that
group so they aren't persecuted
the fact that this is happening is
pretty good evidence that the
persecution is all
uh is all fake finally you know I can't
neglect to mention that today is January
6 2023 and uh that should have been the
number one headline I apologize
it's the two-year two-year anniversary
of um January 6 2021
and that is a day that will live forever
in our memory
as a day that
came right before January 7th 2021.
and even right after January 5th 2021
these were all days
that was a day
today is a day
and that's all that needs to be said
about it let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you own a business the past few years
have been say the least a bumpy ride
from covid lockdowns to bite inflation
you could probably use a break and
Innovation refunds can help you with
that if your business has five or more
employees and manage to survive covid
you could be eligible to receive a
payroll tax rebate of up to twenty six
thousand dollars per employee that isn't
a loan there's no payback it's a refund
of your taxes the challenge is getting
your hands on it how do you cut through
the red tape and get your business the
refund money that you're owed when you
got to go to
getrefunds.com their team of tax
attorneys are highly trained in this
little-known payroll tax refund program
and have already returned a one billion
dollars to businesses and they can help
you too they do all the work with no
charge up front and they simply share a
percentage of the cash that they get for
you businesses of all types can qualify
including those who took uh PPP
non-profits and even those that had
increases in sales but you got to go to
the website go to getrefunds.com click
on qualify me answer a few questions
this payroll tax refund is only
available for a limited amount of time
don't miss out go to getrefunds.com
that's getrefunds.com
cultured anime says we live in a world
where Tate gets arrested before anyone
of Jeffrey Epstein's clients do uh right
and that's and that's a perfectly good
and valid point and I've heard a lot of
people bringing that up and for good
reason because I mean well well whether
Andrew Tate is arrested or not
um the the it's it remains outrageous
that um
that you know they
arrested and then allegedly had this uh
you know Global sex trafficker who was
you know uh associated with all these
very prominent people uh kill himself
even though I didn't really kill himself
and yet and that's the end of it like we
haven't heard anything else about what
what about all these people that he was
was associated with
so apparently it's very it's very
interesting that he's a global sex
trafficker pedophile pimp uh Jeffrey
Epstein and yet he had apparently had no
clients
in fact millions and millions of dollars
and there were and but he didn't have
there was nobody
is what we're supposed to believe
um and as far as Andrew take goes as I
said I I have no idea if he's innocent
or guilty that's that's something that
has to be proven in a court of law
and if they prove it they prove it
um
Harry lagman says fantastic I was
confident you'd get it right about
Andrew Tate both the good sides the less
good and the reasons men like him are
the unsurprising product of a society
that is hostile to boys and men telling
them to be more like women as you say
it's not just a lack of Role Models much
that uh gives boys and men strength that
is attacked I'm thinking specifically
have patriotism the identity with one
with with one's country and the wish to
excel at any job sport or skill but also
the role as a father fathers have been
undermined to a disaster extent by the
law any father if he doesn't know it
already discovers this sooner or later
sometimes very painfully and uh it's not
getting any better
yeah I agree with you as we said in the
opening that the deck legally the deck
is stacked against husbands and fathers
Stefan's men and family court and all
the rest of it
um that's true
but
as I said if we if we respond to that by
just abandoning ship
then we have given
the other side everything they want
there's a re that's the whole reason
that they rig it in this way is that
they want us to give up on the Family
because you have to remember that the
cultural Elites
and the left generally they consider the
family
especially a so-called quote-unquote
traditional family led by a man a father
and a husband they consider that the
enemy
and so if you abandon it then you are
doing exactly what they want you to do
they see every man is going his own way
and is giving up with us and they say
yep thank you
it's exactly what we want
uh Hoosier flatty says are you willing
to reassess your worldview that the
Earth is a moving oblate spheroid
but I have to know what oblate spheroid
means to reassess it but if you mean
that if I'm willing to reassess my
worldview that the world itself is round
uh the answer is is sure yeah they
present the evidence to me if you could
actually present Real evidence that the
Earth is actually flat it's been
everything I think about the world is
wrong
um I'd be fascinated just go ahead tell
me what the evidence is
just that it doesn't exist so that's the
only problem
um look I'm willing to read evidence on
about anything
yeah if you have actual evidence that
the entire that we're living in a
simulation and nothing of none of this
is real and we're all just like brains
in a vat hooked up by wires to some
matrix-like thing
if you have evidence of that I'd be I'd
be fascinated to know
and it'd be great to know because then I
could tell everyone on my podcast and
that would get a lot of views in the
simulation
um
another comment says it's frustrating to
see someone like Matt point out that the
world is [ __ ] on men and then have
him hit on some of the men in children's
lives lump on a log without bothering to
point out the direct cause of these
issues the mother
I'm so sick of the discussion around men
and who and what they should be
tiptoeing around the disastrous choices
that the women in their lives be it a
mother girlfriend wife or peer make
stop blaming men
okay well you seem to be suggesting now
I agree
that we shouldn't blame men for
everything
and we shouldn't just only blame men in
other words like our message to men
should not be one solely of blame
we agree on that
but you're going to the extreme other
end of this and saying that we should
never blame men for anything
which of course is ridiculous
what you're actually claiming here is a
I I mentioned that there are absentee
fathers and there are also plenty of
fathers who are physically present in
the home but are lumps on a law they're
not they're not present in any other way
they're not actually leading their
families that is a real thing that
exists and what you're saying is that in
every single one of those cases it's not
the man's fault it's actually the
woman's fault
do you understand how childish and
ludicrous that is
yeah we don't want to blame men but
don't infantilize them either
nothing is our fault I'm a victim of
everything
so even if you're a man who chooses to
just sit on your ass and play video
games all day and do nothing and you you
have kids and you let your wife do
everything and you do nothing that's not
it's not my fault as you're playing the
video game I can't help it oh please
you know what infantilizing that in that
way is even worse than blaming them
okay heaping scorn and blame on men is
really really bad even worse is
infantilizing them
because at least if you if you point a
finger of blame at man and you say like
at least that might motivate there are
plenty of men who that's they end up
being demoralized and all the rest of it
by it but uh it could also go the other
way see for me when I hear that message
from society it's motivating
that doesn't motivate me in the way that
Society wants to motivate me
but yeah it makes me kind of angry and
that anger sort of like fuels me to to
succeed all the more
so it can have that effect
but in fantalization that's just that
that
it would if if men listen to that they
just become helpless babies
victims
okay never want to be a victim even when
you are a victim you shouldn't see
yourself as a victim
2022 was an incredible year filled with
many accomplishments including the
release of my Smash Hit documentary what
is a woman the rally to end child
mutilation which resulted in Vanderbilt
University Medical Center pausing their
gender affirming surgeries and minor
so-called and I even became 2022's
transphobe of the year and uh that was a
great honor and all this is is really
all well and good but we're just getting
started ringing 2023 with the latest
installment of my patch program which is
the sweet baby New Year patch it's a
beacon for the strides against the left
that we're going to make and the ground
we're going to retake New Year same SBG
it'll sell out fast so you got to go to
dailywire.com shop today also last year
Jordan Peterson joined daily wire plus
and since then he's put out a ton of
inspiring and informative content he
started with Dragons monsters and men
and then as also his series on marriage
and has followed up with logos and
literacy and then his new biblical
series Exodus which is available to
watch right now so far my favorite was
on marriage as we drift further away
from Traditional Values it's no secret
that we're becoming more and more loss
as we drift away from Traditional Values
a lot of this has to do with men
refusing to grow up and people refusing
to enter into marriages like we've
talked about so often on this show
Jordan does a fantastic job of
explaining why marriage is not only
preferable but it's really our true
calling in life there's only one place
where you can watch this and all of
Jordan Peterson's exclusive content and
that's on daily wire plus so head to
dailywire.com Walsh to become a member
and watch all of this and more that's
dillywire.com Walsh today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
over the last few months you had another
popular new trend has been gaining Steam
on Tick Tock although I didn't hear
about it until yesterday when I saw an
interesting video that conservative
commentator Lauren Chen had made on the
subject now it's strange that I would be
so behind the curve on this because as
you all know I'm usually very plugged in
I'm very with it up to date on all the
trends I think I'm known that way in any
case this fashionable new trend is
called the stay-at-home girlfriend
there's a buzzfeed article explains what
it's all about though perhaps it's
rather self-explanatory this is what it
says the day-to-day life of Kendall K
one of tick tock's maligned stay-at-home
girlfriends appears in her viral videos
to be well fairly dull we're jealous her
glamorous not a non-employment doesn't
seem to entail much more than journaling
preparing healthy snacks and seeing an
occasional butterfly on Twitter people
say that she seems like she has been
lobotomized highly medicated or
generally unfulfilled her meticulous
self-care and fitness routines a symptom
of the spreading that girl aesthetic
have been compared to that of American
psycho's serial killer Patrick Bateman
parody videos abound but her Slow Soft
life resonated with many instead of
criticizing her lack of a nine to five
they related to the dream of one day
being rich enough to have a do-nothing
job we've long been on the verge of a
hustle culture Reckoning and K is one
post away from leading the revolution is
it possible some of these critics were
just jealous too
now there are apparently many videos on
Tick Tock of these stay-at-home
girlfriends showing what their sort of
day-to-day life is like here's a
sampling from The Tick tocker mentioned
in that article here it is
this is my day in the life as a
stay-at-home girlfriend I'm currently in
Vancouver so I'm in a new house which is
so fun and the first thing I do is take
my aloe shot I love having this on an
empty stomach and I take my greens
then I get straight to making Luke's
coffee because he's definitely a
caffeine first thing in the morning kind
of guy
I am adding some honey and cream and I
made these cookies yesterday so I'm
gonna give him a couple of those to eat
with his coffee then I sit down and do
some journaling and some reading
and then I get to making myself a matcha
with some cinnamon and ground ginger and
then I add some cashew milk on top yum
then I do my skin care and my LED mask
and then some ice rolling
just love doing the longest skincare
routine in the morning
then I love to open all the blinds in
the house and get all the sunlight I can
and make the bed of course to keep the
house tidy and looking its best
then it's time to make some breakfast
I've been loving these oats lately well
you probably get the idea they're
actually her morning routine is a lot
like mine
um you know I Stumble out of the
out of uh my room and I'm like just
barely awake and my kids try to talk to
me and say don't don't talk to me until
I have my aloe shot in Greens
and do my skincare routine with the ice
roller whatever that is uh no actually
that doesn't happen but at least the
part where she makes coffee I can relate
to that the rest of it not so much but
uh as the BuzzFeed piece alluded to not
everyone is on board with the
stay-at-home girlfriends as is always
the case with a tick tock Trend there
has arisen a competing trend of videos
explaining why the other trend is deeply
problematic problematic and critics are
primarily concerned that stay-at-home
girlfriends are living a terribly
unfeminist life having deprived
themselves of the empowerment and glamor
of the cubicle in favor of living under
the misogynistic tyranny of a boyfriend
who provides for their every need
according to these critics you know a
woman is is supposed to put on a pant
suit and go to work and climb the
corporate ladder a life that is so
famously liberating and enriching to the
soul
she's certainly not meant to be at home
meanwhile other critics have decided
that it is of course racist to be a
stay-at-home girlfriend here's user
fazioli breadstick explaining this logic
this reminded me of a thread I saw on
Twitter the other
compository but this
you should definitely pause and read her
take on it once again I just want to
reiterate that it's not my business or
anybody else's for that matter what you
choose to do whether you work or don't
work and let me be very clear that when
I'm talking about the stay-at-home
girlfriend Trend I'm not talking about
how other cultures divide labor in the
household rather I am talking about the
very recent cultural phenomenon in which
white women in particular romanticize
the idea of opting out of Labor that is
otherwise delegated to lower income
people and people of color what do
videos like these tell you about a who
gets to rest B who deserves rest and see
how you get rest I find it interesting
that in these videos nobody is calling
these women lazy or gold diggers in fact
most of them are concerned that they're
being taken advantage of when you look
at most social movements and political
movements upper white middle class women
are nowhere to be found because if they
wanted to create meaningful social
change they could they choose not to
because it goes against their class
interests they're my drop by
right no one is calling these women lazy
or gold diggers except for all the
thousands of people who are calling them
exactly that this is very common on the
left they'll often declare you know when
white people do fill in the blank nobody
criticizes them for it yet in reality
everyone criticizes them for it
including the person claiming they're
not being criticized for it
indeed the truth is the other way around
usually if it was primarily black women
making a stay-at-home girlfriend videos
then you wouldn't be allowed to
criticize it
but in this case Miss breadstick seems
to be arguing that because so many
racial minorities are not able to opt
out of the labor force white women
shouldn't opt out either they must be
allies they must make their lifestyle
decisions based on what other people are
doing
they're not allowed to be happy because
that would be unfair to all of the
racial minorities who Miss breadstick
assumes are not happy
this is allyship and here allyship
specifically means apparently getting a
job in the service industry even if you
don't need it or want it
which only means that you'll be taking a
position away from someone potentially
racial minority who does need it and
want it so I don't think that Miss
breadstick has thought this all the way
through
but these criticisms are all you know of
course extremely stupid
it may be unfeminist to become a
stay-at-home girlfriend but there's
nothing wrong with being unfeminist on
the contrary that's the lane that any
woman should want to be in considering
that feminists are also resentful and
miserable
if you don't know which way you want to
go in life uh and you're a woman you you
could do worse than simply just looking
at whatever feminists are doing and
heading in the exact opposite direction
it's also obviously not racist to live
your own life how you want to live it
you're not morally required to conduct a
racial inventory before making every
decision in your life and even if you
did conduct the inventory there there's
no point to it because according to the
left it's racist for a white person to
do things that black people aren't doing
but it's also racist to do things that
they are doing
so there's no sense in playing a game
that you can't win uh and and that's why
all these uh criticisms are ridiculous
but here's a criticism
of the state home girlfriend Trend that
is not ridiculous
the real problem
with the stay-at-home girlfriend
lifestyle is not the stay-at-home part
it's the girlfriend part
the problem of course is that these
women aren't married that's the issue
what this trend actually represents is a
is a broader Trend uh in a continued
attempt by many people in our culture to
figure out a way to enjoy the benefits
of marriage without actually getting
married
so many young people and young couples
they seek to take on the form of a
married relationship mimic it but
without the substance of the marriage
they're playing house they're playing
pretend
and that's where this trend truly
becomes to use the less favorite term
problematic
that's what you actually see in that
video it is it is a a woman is just like
it's it's house your playing house
it is a more sophisticated game of house
the problems here are many but we will
um briefly focus on just one
you know both the stay-at-home
girlfriend and the working boyfriend
have made themselves incredibly
vulnerable here
and they have set themselves up for and
nearly inevitable and inevitably messy
and heartbreaking split
because the girl is relying on the guy
entirely to subsidize her lifestyle
relying on him to bring home the bacon
and bring home everything else too and
yet the one thing she doesn't have from
him the one thing he's not providing
even if she seems to have everything
else is any sort of meaningful
commitment
she is leaning on him completely but he
can just step to the side at any moment
and send her crashing to the floor
he hasn't even promised not to do that
he hasn't so much as promised not to
step to the side
indeed by not marrying her he has
promised that eventually he will abandon
because that's the whole reason why you
refuse to get married to someone is
because you want to leave your you want
to leave that escape hatch in place
a refusal to commit is a commitment of
its own you are committing to Breaking
Up Down the Line eventually
and when that day comes you know the the
breakup of this non-committed
effectively meaningless relationship
will be very messy and difficult much
more messy and difficult than a breakup
between boyfriend and girlfriend ought
to be because normally dumping your
girlfriend should require no more than
one awkward conversation and that's it
you go your separate ways and you never
have to speak to each other again
if you don't want to that's the way it
should go if you're just dating someone
that's the whole point of dating that's
one of the things that's supposed to
separate it from marriage is that you're
not in really entangled in any way you
just you're living your own lives you're
dating and if you want to live one life
together that's why you get married
and the great thing is that if you're
not if you're living separate lives and
then you decide that okay we're not
going to get married this isn't going to
work out just go your separate ways
that's it
you'll be sad about it for a while but
you'll get over it
once you've added houses and mortgages
into the mix
then when you when you've taken on many
of the obligations and shared roles of a
marriage even though you aren't married
you end up with a breakup that feels and
looks an awful lot like a divorce
so
you never had the benefit of the
marriage
but you still get the crap storm of the
divorce
it's the worst of all worlds
and then the guy in this Arrangement is
no bet is in no better shape he's
working every day and providing for a
woman who has made no commitment to him
he has taken on a dependent and yet
still has no wife
he is a man with no wife no children no
marriage no family and yet still has a
dependent that he's taken care of every
day
you know there's that crass expression
often used to describe a man with a
living girlfriend they say well you know
he's getting the milk for free so why
buy the cow
but the truth is that he's the cow in
this scenario he's being used by a woman
who again has made no promises to him no
commitment no oath of fealty
she could be spending part of her ample
free time every day in bed with some
other guy she met at the gym or whatever
and she wouldn't even be violating any
vow by doing so because no vow was ever
made
the guy can't even say you broke your
promise I Never Promised anything to you
not officially
we couldn't even call it an affair
because they aren't married so it's not
an affair
she would be cheating yes but cheating
what an ambiguous relationship where no
official promises or commitments have
ever been made
so what
this is why if you want to enjoy a
relationship that looks and acts like a
marriage there is no substitute for
actually getting married no matter how
desperately our culture looks for a
substitute it's just not there
and that is why even after defending
these stay-at-home girlfriends from some
of their especially stupid critics I
must still say that the state home
girlfriends are
unfortunately canceled although they
could just graduate to being stay at
home wives and mothers and then that
would be a whole other story entirely
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign